so i want to tell you about really quite
exciting paper about a new very white
paint not only is it very white
but it can actually cool things down
act a bit like air conditioning when
it's hot outside
before that let me just remind you how a
greenhouse works
and the greenhouse as you know has sun
light shining on it it gets warmer
inside
than it is outside and the way that it
works
is that the sunlight which is short
wavelength
light can go through the glass and it's
absorbed
by whatever is inside the greenhouse the
plants and so on
they get warm up because they've
absorbed the sunlight
and then they give out heat a much
longer wavelength and that heat
radiation cannot get out through the
glass
the heat is trapped inside and it gets
very hot
now this paint works in the exact
opposite way it uses
a material called barium sulphate
it's quite easy to make i asked neil to
make some for us
and you take a solution of barium
chloride
barium is the element two below
calcium in the periodic table so you
make
a solution dissolving the barium
chloride
in water and you get a colorless
solution
and then you add dilute sulfuric acid
and barium sulfate is
insoluble or almost insoluble in water
so you get a sort of snow storm
of tiny barium sulfate crystals
precipitating out and it looks really
beautiful
you see these swirling clouds brady
who's hard to impress wanted to see it
twice
[Music]
[Music]
so it is a really nice reaction it's
also
quite a good test for barium if you want
to
show that you've got a solution of
barium add a little sulfuric acid
down it comes however what has been done
in this very recent article is that they
have used
a mixture of different size particles of
barium sulfate
and mixed it in a binder so you can make
white paint
normally the white paints that you and i
use
uses titanium dioxide tio2
which reflects visible light
but absorbs ultraviolet light and also
absorbs
infrared light so if you have something
painted with
titanium dioxide it reflects the visible
light
but absorbs the uv in infrared so the
surface gets warm from the sun
this new paint reflects nearly
all the wavelengths from the sunlight so
all the energy of the sun is sent back
again
and because of all these different sized
particles
it's much more effective than titanium
dioxide paint
but and here's the exciting thing
barium sulfate is transparent in the
infrared
so the heat radiating out from whatever
is under the paint
can go through the barium sulfate paint
and radiate out into space or into the
atmosphere
so what is below is giving out heat
but it's not receiving any heat from the
sunlight so it can be
colder than the air outside
or the warmth from the sun
so you can get something that is
called radiative cooling and according
to this article
even in winter when it's really cold
the surface under the paint can be
cooler than the paint itself
and their suggestion is that if we all
painted
the roofs of our houses white
it would give us a really effective way
of keeping the house cool
without using any source of energy
as we would with air conditioning now
i'm not sure whether in this house you
could paint the roof
white but in many countries it would be
possible
and this could really be quite a big
advance in providing
a nice cool environment for us to live
without adding to the
co2 emissions that will contribute to
global warming
individual micron scale micron diameter
particles
and you can see that they're moving
across you can see them moving around in
the solution
and they're joining on here they're
aggregating at the edge they're falling
out of solution